le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
reprend ce mardi à paris ce sont les
proches des terroristes qui doivent être
auditionnés alors que deux accusés
refuse toujours de comparaître on va
retrouver notre reporter katia pique
nique en direct du palais de justice de
paris
katia bonjour ce sont donc les proches
des terroristes qui sont entendus cet
après midi
oui absolument actuellement à la barre
le père de najim lâchera wiki un des
deux kamikazes de l'aéroport de
bruxelles il est suspecté d'avoir
également participé à l'organisation des
attentats du 13 novembre alors comme
vous le disais les parents les proches
la famille des accusés défilent à la
barre depuis la semaine dernière avec
des dépositions de témoins comme le père
de samia me mourou sa soeur terroristes
du bataclan des témoins qui laisse les
victimes sur leur faim car il les
suspecte d'en savoir beaucoup et de ne
pas dire ce qu'elles savent ou encore de
ne pas en savoir assez ce qui vous ne
permet donc pas de répondre à toutes
leurs interrogations
alors par exemple le père de najim
nasraoui explique il ne s'entendait pas
avec son fils qui n'étaient pas d'accord
pour son départ en syrie qui lui a
confisqué son passeport milk il a quand
même réussi à partir et qui l'a gardé
contact avec son fils peu de temps après
son départ qui n'a pas voulu par le
rejoindre en syrie bien sûr c'était un
enfant très gentil pourquoi at il fait
ça c'est un point d'interrogation dit
son père qui n'arrivait même pas à
expliquer comment il était en doctrine
et pourquoi pas requis enfin vous
imaginez la frustration des parties
civiles face à ce type de témoignage
alors avant cela de très nombreuses
journées ont été consacrées aux
auditions des enquêteurs belges ils ont
décortiqué le parcours des accusés leurs
liens entre eux pour un grand nombre
leur circuit avec la syrie et puis il ya
eu des polémiques concernant ces
enquêtes jugées insuffisantes par
quelques avocats des parties civiles ans
qui estime qu' il y a beaucoup de trous
dans la raquette beaucoup d'imprécisions
de manque de connaissance
plus ce qui est certain c'est que la
police belge disposer d'un indice très
inquiétant par exemple sur brahim ben
abdeslam le faire de sales abdeslam qui
a même été arrêtée quelques mois avant
les attentats puis finalement relâché
donc encore une fois de la frustration
vous parlez aussi des absents au procès
c'est à dire les accusés qui refusent de
comparaître il y en a eu entre 5 et 2
selon les jours la raison c'est parce
que les enquêteurs belges ont été
entendus en visioconférence en tout
anonymat et cela les accusés ne l'ont
pas supporté donc aujourd'hui il y en a
encore deux qui manquent à l'appel
merci à beaucoup avouent 4 ça pique
nique pour toutes ces précisions en
direct du palais de justice de paris